[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à tous tout de suite
notre sommaire avec cette question
emmanuel macron fait-il du
catastrophisme lors de ses récentes
interventions il a évoqué le spectre de
l'entre-deux-guerres et la dangereuse
mécanique propice à un embrasement
mondiale ce qui est frappant c'est que
d'autres dirigeants ce sont aussi le
tocsin nous avons préparé un florilège
de ses discours
parmi la montée des périls il ya
évidemment le terrorisme islamique trois
ans après les attentats du 13 novembre
cette menace est elle suffisamment
prises en compte par le gouvernement
nous en débattrons nous parlerons aussi
du feuilleton de la semaine les gilet
jaune à quatre jours des blocages le
gouvernement cherche activement une
issue de secours
mais n'est-il pas trop tard face à
l'ampleur du ras-le-bol fiscale enfin
nous vous posons cette question
cornélienne êtes vous plutôt michelle
obama ou jean d'ormesson
l'ancienne première dame américaine et
l'académicien mort l'an dernier sortent
ces jours ci les livres de ces deux
personnalités nous allons en parler avec
vous ils anna sécurel merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes membre du
bureau exécutif de la république en
marche vous êtes également à vos tables
et vous avez d'excellents diplôme en
droit philosophie à leur merci nous
avoir rejoints
l'accueil karine des cas bonjour vous
êtes journaliste politique à france
inter vous avez couvert longtemps la
droite vous occupez aujourd'hui à
majorité exactement vous connaissez sans
doute il est ainsi qu elle connaissait
pas a annoncé dès le début j'ai eu c'est
parce qu'on n'est pas c'est pas son rôle
exact
jérôme jaffré bonjour vous êtes
politologue direct dirigé le centre
d'études et de connaissances sur
l'opinion publique c'est le secope si
beaucoup de diplômes quelques-uns et ne
rivalise pas vous avez publié le front
national face à l'obstacle du second
tour
c'était la fondation pour l'innovation
politique en 2017 et bonjour alexis
brézet et directeur des rédactions du
figaro
alors on va commencer tout de suite par
notre premier thème revenir sur ce
centenaire du 11 novembre et la tonalité
de ces commémorations elle était grave
elle ne porte guère à l'optimisme pour
l'avenir de la paix à commencer par le
discours donc des manuels macro on va
tout de suite en voir un extrait c'était
dimanche après midi à l'ouverture du
forum sur la paix l'histoire retiendra
sans doute une image celle de 84 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement réunis sous
l'arc de triomphe dans la paix mais ce
qui demeure incertain pour l'avenir
c'est la façon dont sera interprété
cette image seras tu es le symbole
éclatant d'une paix durable entre les
nations ou au contraire la photographie
d'un dernier moment d'unité avant que le
monde ne sombre dans un nouveau désordre
alors certains reproches qu'on sente au
président d'agiter le spectre avec une
arrière pensée politique
mais ce qui est frappant c'est donc à
quel point d'autres responsables de
premier rang d'un niveau international
10 à peu près la même chose regardez on
a préparé un petit florilège de ces
déclarations avec celle d'angela merkel
toujours à l'ouverture du forum sur la
paix qu'on peut le voir la paix que nous
avons aujourd'hui qui nous paraît
parfois trop évidente cette paix est
tout sauf évidente et antonio guterres
est ce aussi le secrétaire général de
l'onu qui dit bien des éléments ensemble
aujourd'hui emprunter au début du 20e
siècle et aux années 30
il laisse craindre un engrenage
invisible christine lagarde encore
directrice du fmi qui dans une interview
qu'elle donnait aux échos ce week-end
disaient les élections récentes ont été
la poussée des populismes pour dire une
appétence pour des régimes autoritaires
qui est vraiment préoccupante et enfin
on va terminer avec cette déclaration
d'un ancien proche de tuer obama un tony
blick haine qui était son secrétaire
d'état adjoint et qui disait je résume
mais vous pouvez lire lors de sa
déclaration
est ce qu'un choc titanesque nous
rendrait la mémoire jérôme jaffré cette
succession de déclarations c'est
finalement de la lucidité ou c'est un
spectre agité pour faire un peu peur et
pour emmanuel macron avec effectivement
une arrière pensée politique
mon sentiment c'est quand même qu'on
mélange plusieurs notions dans le même
discours des uns et des autres c'est à
dire que il ya le populisme il ya les
régimes autoritaires et ya la paix qu'il
faut préserver ces trois problèmes
différents en réalité un ce que veut
dire emmanuel macron cet intéressant
dans l'extrait que vous avez passé c'est
qu'il a parlé d'un monde dans lequel il
n'y aurait plus d'unité c'est à dire le
risque c'est l'absence de coopération
l'absence de dialogue la fin du
multilatéralisme qui a dominé l'après
guerre et qui a été un élément
absolument fondamental de la paix que
nous connaissons en france depuis en
europe depuis 73 ans excusez du peu
c'est tout à fait considérable mais ça
n'est pas pour autant qu'il y a des
attitudes agressives un nationalisme
agressif et guerrier comme il pouvait y
en avoir dans les années 30 c'est pour
ça que je trouve qu'on mélange un petit
peu les choses
populisme et autoritarisme c'est pas
exactement la même chose non plus mais
pour emmanuel macron ça lui permettait
de sortir de la notion de progressisme
son opposition entre progressistes et
mondialiste qui manifestement ne
fonctionnait pas bien il est aisé à
beaucoup de gens ont politiquement en
france et ailleurs et donc ça lui
permettait de parler d'autre chose
le patriotisme d'ouverture contre le
nationalisme de repli vous répondez à
jérôme jaffré
oui leur prochain match
c'est ça c'est à dire c'est moi ou le
chaos en gros je crois qu'il n'a pas
tout à fait dit ça il extrait le
montrent il pose une question il pose
une question en disant est ce que ce
rassemblement
deux des dirigeants qui avaient
d'ailleurs quelque chose d'assez
impressionnant sous la pluie avec avec
ces voix là c'est parapluie 7
est-ce que ça va être la veille d'une
catastrophe ou ou le réveil vers au
contraire plus de coopération et une
prise donc je crois qu'on n'est d'ap moi
j'entends j'entends le message non pas
comme un catastrophisme annoncé mais
comme nous sommes à la croisée des
chemins
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins et
tout va dépendre de nous et c'est très
important parce que héraclite l'avait
dit avant nous on se baigne jamais deux
fois dans le même fleuve
il s'agit pas d'une histoire qui se
répète l'histoire ne se répète pas par
contre comme l'a écrit pascal ory dans
le monde dans un article assez complexe
il y a des analogies
il y a des effets de structure qu'il
faut savoir entendre
et oui nous sommes dans une période
quand même qui est qui est inquiétante
rappelons-nous même au niveau national
on a eu le front national qui était au
deuxième tour on n'aurait pas imaginé il
ya une dizaine d'années en tout cas en
tout cas c'est extrêmement inquiétant
alors évidemment vous avez vous savez un
peu une théorie du complot type qui veut
que si jamais on en profite
alors ça veut dire que ont créé le
problème c'est pas emmanuel macron qui
crée cette ce contexte quand même assez
inquiétant avec montée des régimes
autoritaires avec une fragilisation du
droit de la presse du des droits des
femmes
il y a des éléments d'inquiétude qu'il
faut prendre au prix quand karim b car
il en fait trop selon vous où il pose
les bonnes questions
hydra matic les enjeux ça c'est certain
il est rabatis devant un aéropage de 84
chefs d'état et de gouvernement et je
dirais que c'était sans doute le lieu
pour le faire et les français n'ont pas
été surpris tout le monde sait que
encore les tweets aujourd'hui de donald
trump qui sonne la charge
au même moment durant durant ce week-end
à netanyahou qui finalement rentrer plus
vite que prévu en israël parce que voilà
s'embraser la situation a été compliquée
également pour israël donc il fallait y
aller on sait ce qui se passe en syrie
on sait ce qui se passe au yémen
on s'est même ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de notre europe c'est
compliqué avec l'italie s'est compliquée
avec la grande-bretagne donc tout ça les
français sont capables de comprendre on
a un emmanuel macron qui dramatise des
gens je les enjeux et c'est sa place
finalement au niveau international il le
pouvait il l'a fait et ça lui donne un
leadership international en revanche si
on met ça avec ce qui s'est passé sous
le nom de son allocution juste après le
deuxième remaniement du à la mi-octobre
là donc il ya un mois où il est il est
pareil dans la dramatisation des enjeux
il est dans moi ou le chaos mettez vous
chers français derrière moi parce qu'il
ya que moi qui avec les élections
européennes qui sont au bout du chemin
peut vous sauver
là par contre il ya une récupération
politique à mon avis donc en fonction de
ceux à qui s'adressent ils jouent pas le
jeu politique
l ex il est je crois que je vois sur les
dix rebelles macro marecek que le pur
fête pour célébrer le centenaire à me
sentir bien ça la grande guerre que
célébrer la paire dissidence est un
idéal qu'il faut toujours défendre est
toujours mise en péril ça ne veut pas
dire grand chose c'est sympathique et
personne n'aurait rien eu à redire c'est
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'autre chose
que pour célébrer la fin d'une guerre
que de dire qu' il faut ce qu'il faut et
et d'émouvoir la paix donc ça y est
absolument rien à dire ce qui me paraît
en revanche plus problématique est au
fond plus choquant c'est cette
utilisation
aujourd'hui en novembre et depuis
effectivement pas mal de semaines de
cette thématique des années 30 des
années sombres des moments des passions
les expressions très centriste n'ont
alors pas sur dix ans encore un vieux
truc mais enfin c'est toujours la même
thématique mais les années 30 les
passions sur les retours des années
noires etc
ça me parait hollande comme dans un
cadre d' instrumentalisation politique
qui est absolument pas tant qui est
d'abord moralement assez choquant
divisés au fond le nazisme et cette
période et le stalinisme cette période
terrible à des fins politiques qui est
historiquement extrêmement contestable
parce que malgré tout on a le droit de
trouver que trump est très méchant on a
droit trouvait que les hongrois sont pas
gentils que les polonais sont pas
formidables que les maintenant les
roumains paraît-il ne sont pas bien bon
on peut être on peut dire dis ça mais
qui peut croire que parmi ces gens là il
ya hitler staline ou mussolini
c'est des blagues ça n'est pas vrai il
fait souvent le louvre âge de sa liste
de ministres au lien les somnambules en
dire il faut qu'on se réveille
où sont les idéologies aujourd'hui qui
de conquête de l'europe et
d'extermination de l'adversaire ou d'une
ethnie
ça n'est pas vrai mieux alors il y en a
eu il y en a qu'une
justement donc celle dont il ne parle
pas aujourd'hui c'est l'islamisme et ça
il n'en parle pas et images
il va je comprends très bien qu'on
combatte trump si on peut le combattre
ou orban houleux où les roumains mais
mais de là à nous raconter la blague des
années 30 ça me parait ça pas de tir
debout et j'ajouterais j'en ai fini que
politiquement cette affaire là mettez
désastreuse parce que se mettre dans
cette fin ce cas de figure la
d'expliquer dès que les peuples quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec eux dire c'est
ce sont les passions tristes c'est le
nazisme sellette mais c'est ce c'est
demain se retrouver en situation
minoritaire
et au fond servir de porte de deux
marches pièce est de loger là donc c'est
politiquement absurde
un dernier mois jérôme sur le grill et
j'ajoute de mon bouquin que ferland
titre up
évidemment c'est rentable politiquement
parce que papa dire que l'image de 30
soit excellente fait revenir le
président des états unis à paris le 11
novembre 2018 pour célébrer le
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale sans saluer le peuple américain
ce que les américains ont fait pour nous
permettre de gagner la première guerre
mondiale pour nous permettre d'être
libérée du nazisme dans la deuxième
guerre mondiale de remercier les
américains de leur contribution à la
paix depuis les 60 présents dont je
parle faire la leçon à trump comme il
l'a fait dimanche me paraît être si vous
excusez moi un impair grave du point de
vue des relations internationales et du
point de vue des relations franco
américaines dont nous voyons
dès aujourd'hui les conséquences parce
que trois
la série d'ondés tous manifestement
déchaîné de donald trump au réveil on va
en parler dans un instant je donne juste
quelques réactions d'abord la réponse à
la question qu'on vous posez sur
lefigaro.fr selon vous la france est
elle pardon c'est pas tout à fait celle
là c'est la question du jour d'hier
c'était croyez vous possible une
nouvelle guerre en europe et la réponse
était oui à plus de 62%
donc il ya quand même une crainte qui
s'exprime sur le forcément une idéologie
nazie et à nouveau il s'agit pas d'une
répétition
mais l'histoire se répète pas donc on ne
sait pas quel visage elle prendra et
vous avez raison on n'est plus dans les
grandes idéologies mais par contre mais
parce que parce que la délinquance dont
il attend des commandes ce qui attendait
dans le détroit dans les structures
récurrence si vous permettez dans les
structures récurrente il y a le fait on
ne croit plus dans les jouets de la
philo dans les institutions dans dans
les dents les institutions qui de
stabilité et or on assiste là la chute
de l'europe vous savez il ya un vrai
danger
la désintégration de l'europe ne vous
semble-t-elle pas pu voir remettre en
cause non mais ce qui nous a protégés
c'est le rôle de roi dodo craindre
l'assemblée nationale a contacté par et
de leurs entrepôts la société le proche
d'hervé n'est pas le projet de la
société des nations
heureusement pas passer de ce n'est pas
la même chose à nous sommes dans un
monde où tout va bien nous nous montrait
très bas mais préfère m'en ces zones
dont on parle pas l'idéologie
aujourd'hui de conquête les objets
qu'ils présentent qui prétend imposer sa
domination philosophiques religieuses
militaires civiles à une partie du monde
c'est l'islam il faudrait peut-être en
parler plutôt que de parler des hongrois
ou d'héroïne enfin il en parle très bien
les secours n'étaient pas ce jour là ce
n'était pas le jour mais il n'aura rien
karine bk je voulais vous dire quelque
chose par rapport à ce qui vient d'être
dit par par vous monsieur jaffray sur
sur le rapport la relation entre trump
et emmanuel macron oui il y en a bien un
père qui est fait de la part du
président français ce week end on a je
crois un président qui est aujourd'hui
gêné dans sa relation avec les états
unis par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
lors de sa visite d'état où il s'est
complètement laissée déborder en tout
cas les choses sont pas passées
exactement comme il le souhaitait et
aujourd'hui
presque envie de dire c'est une relation
totalement à reconstruire un rapport et
vous pensez que dimanche le discours de
dimanche contribuer à reconstruire cette
relation alors non sachant suis pas
certaine
enfin s'intéressaient pas directement
d'amérique on va voir dans un instant
quand je vois je donne tu as une
quelques réactions des internautes sur
ce sujet emmanuel macron dit julien a
reflété dimanche dernier une image
positive de la france dans le monde
entier donc plutôt saluant leur stature
internationale anti mac n'est pas tout à
fait du même avis tous les discours de
macron sont centrés sur lui même
monsieur babineau nous dit je trouve que
macron ces riches comme le rempart aux
forces du mal alors je sais pas si la
tonalité est ironique ou pas vous
l'interprétez comme vous voulez anti mac
toujours macron ne nous parlent jamais
du danger islamique du danger potentiel
de certains pays émergents
donc on va parler donc de ses tweets
alors c'était au petit matin sans doute
pour donald trump au réveil un réveil de
mauvaise humeur ou en tout cas pas très
francophile ce matin puisqu'il nous dit
il fait des allusions alors il ya un peu
de tout il ya d'abord la question de la
popularité rappelle emmanuel macron
control est à peu près à 40% de l'hôtel
et lui rappelle le président en france
après il dit que l'europe de la défense
c'est une chose mais enfin que quand
même c'était l'allemagne qui était
l'adversaire de la france pendant les
deux premiers conflits mondiaux que s'il
n'a pas pu aller au cimetière américain
c'était à cause du mauvais temps et que
20 bon voilà et ensuite il ironise aussi
sur l'histoire des femmes et en disant
que finalement c'est pas normal que les
vins français s'exportent si bien aux
états unis mais que les vins américains
soit se voient appliquer des tarifs
douaniers trop élevé en france donc que
dire vous l'avez dit un petit peu déjà
je remplis à près de sept salves vous
vous interpréter ça comme la réponse à
la mauvaise mauvaise manière en tout cas
le fait qu'il était impossible et hier
que les américains n'étaient pas et vous
avez 4 64 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui sont là pour célébrer
fin de la première guerre mondiale et la
paix et vous vous donner la leçon au
président américain car c'est une charge
la fameuse phrase qui est mes intérêts
d'abord et peu importe ceux des autres
est prononcé dans le discours d'
emmanuel macron répond à america first
la devise du président américain du
nationalisme oui mais mais se reconnaît
qu'il faudra vous ne pensez pas qu'il a
fait la leçon à trump dans le discours
qu'il a prononcé dimanche vous n'avez
pas entendu comme ça vous avez pensé que
c'était des amabilités pour le président
américain le discours je pense que
l'opposition nationaliste patriotique
patriotes nationale nationaliste
elle est importante elle est
structurante seulement et elle est
nouvelle et elle est porteuse car la
jeunesse issue le agréé six semaines en
marche à 15 margot apparemment le
problème parce qu'avant le président
macron opposait les progressistes aux
mondialistes
c'était se sentait absolument
fondamental il vient de disparaître
terminé et maintenant nous sommes
effectivement entre les patriotes et les
nationalistes ce qui est plus clair
certainement mais ça si ce que ça
signifie pas que vous le progressisme on
avait réussi en marche et ne lui donnait
aucun contenu abc et d'ailleurs
une réflexion il ya toujours une
réflexion course est toujours évidemment
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux pour ne pas
pour ne pas s'endormir mais je crois que
c'est une c'est une bonne chose parce
que le progressisme encore faut-il
s'entendre sur ce qu'il se dit ce qu'il
recèle et moi je lui donne je lui donne
un sens si vous voulez liés aux lumières
on pourrait en débattre et je pense
qu'il ya une manière d'armé cette ce
concept mais il me semble que de revenir
sur l'idée de souveraineté européenne de
patriotisme européen est quelque chose
de très positif parce que c'est une
manière de dire aussi à tous ceux qui
doutent aujourd'hui nous avons entendu
vos inquiétudes nous avez l'europe qui
protège les neurones ans il n'y a que
l'europe qui peut être une réponse à
toutes les questions et qui sont
soulevées donc je pense que ça en a
l'air
angela merkel a apporté de l'eau au
moulin des mails à matran cet après-midi
parce que devant le parlement européen à
strasbourg elle a défendu à son tour
l'idée d'une armée européenne je le
précise en disant que nous devons
élaborer une vision nous permettant un
jour de parvenir à une véritable armée
européenne a dit la chancelière
karine d'écart sur ce sujet et sur la
réponse aussi à ce que jérôme jaffré 10
est sûre c'est finalement vous vous
dites c'est rome qui a commencé en
insultant disant que les propos de
macron étaient insultants et qui a le
même un peu la mèche dès vendredi avoir
seulement dit dès que oui je pense que
la relation est devenue extrêmement
compliquée avec cette visite d'état où
emmanuel macron pensait réussir à
montrer au monde entier qu'il avait une
relation très particulière très
singulière et est très filiale avec avec
donald trump et finalement il serait
complètement manger bon à la suite de
tout ça et effectivement quand tu y mets
le code donald trump arrive en france
là ce week-end la terrible ou trump et
poussettes l'abaissant de maquereau qui
est contre elle et elle était fille
terrible oui bon on va pas revenir sur
tout ça là où revanche
je vais pas tout à fait la même analyse
que vous pour moi et mon imac ronde ans
que j'entends ce week end continue à
être mais pas seulement à être dans son
opposition progressiste contre
nationaliste et pas mondialistes parce
que il me semble lille un glissement
voilà pour graisser mondialistes pas un
bon alors admettons mais est aujourd'hui
enfin depuis ce week end la notion qui
rajoute effectivement c'est une notion
de patriotisme parce que il me semble
qu'il ne veut pas laisser la nation
cette notion si importante
il ne veut pas laisser la nation aux
nationalistes dont kylie 7 en saillie
lake en saillie là elle sans doute dû
écouter un certain nombre de 2 c de ses
commandes de ses conseillers du soir qui
viennent le voir et notamment au premier
rang françois bayrou il avait dit
surtout n'abandonne pas la notion de
nation tu t'en banderet des doigts donc
il me semble que c'est juste un décalage
qui était nécessaire parce que depuis
depuis que nous on observe effectivement
cette opposition entre progressiste
nationalistes on voit que ces vins on
voit quoi on en arrive à un référendum
pour ou contre l'union européenne et que
ça allait gentiment se retourner contre
emmanuel macron donc il est en train de
mettre quelques petits cailloux pour
infléchir tout doucement son discours
moi j'ai juste entendu ça secoue
dernière tentative de correction
sélection est en régression des yankees
permis la nation dans le camp des
méchants parce que exactement et donc il
va livrer la patrie ou alors on va nous
faire le grand coup que la patrie tu
sais pas si vous vous souvenez du film
la boum vigueur et ô combien france et à
l'école je vais être en quoi alors l
hérault seconde non un peu comme sa mère
ça me paraît pas excusez moi mais plutôt
que la boue moi je les cite et romain
gary qui disait que le patriotisme et la
loue et c'est ce qu'on va l'amener siens
et le national on va enfin moi je dis ça
mais bon gars et franchement c'est pas
le site on le hall on lui on lui dit et
ça elle revient en disant j'ai appris un
truc formidable naturisme franchement
est ce que vous croyez que les poilus et
est patriote et pas nationaliste ou
nationalistes et patriotes par donc je
pense que c'est comme de la rhétorique
qui nous emmène pas très loin alors je
comprends que ayant donné la nation aux
seins ils veulent récupérer la patrie
mais c'est c'est quand même des jeux de
2-2 ce mot de trucs qui veulent pas dire
grand chose un nationalisme et
nationalisme intelligent alors qu un
nationalisme et à le remplir oui je
serai un nationalisme fermé le produit
mais voilà alors maintenant c'est
patrice nationalisme ce qui est il reste
ne restent pas moins de tout ça que
effectivement je pense que monsieur mac
on s'est rendu compte qu'à donner à
l'adversaire
la nation c'est dangereux c'était
dangereux et d'eau qu'ils essaient de
récurer les progressistes n'avait pas
compté que le mcg progressisme basse
on ne meurt pas pour le progressisme
c'est la grande désirons donner ça
dépend ce que vous y mettez quelqu'un va
jouer je pense qu'on a encore des gens
qui font aimer vous saluer en tout cas
ça je crains ce qu'a déjà fait un fils
oui mais je pense que c'est une feinte
c'est à dire que après faut être
vraiment les choses mais de dire la
nation c'est mal la patrie c'est bien je
pense que c'est pas exact n'a pas de
vrai sens au delà des mots et de la
rhétorique c'est qui s'est remise à
notre madame le nord il y en assez terne
on avait aussi réalisé d'un patriotisme
le contrat nationaliste on peut débattre
en avant du temps on est en confiance et
que soulever alexis c'est à dire et à la
faveur de deux des trois ans des
attentats aujourd'hui l'idée que la
menace terroriste islamique elle n'a pas
disparu
le nouveau secrétaire d'état à
l'intérieur d'ailleurs laurent nunez qui
a dirigé le service de renseignement l'a
résumé dans une interview qui donnait au
journal du dimanche ce week-end il dit
la menace elle est moins probable venant
de syrie et de l'état islamique mais
c'est un gros mais il ya un vivier en
france d'islamistes capable de passer à
l'acte du jour au lendemain on a un
voile ces propos à l'écran c'est du
langage de techniciens d'antiterrorisme
maintenant regardez ce que
ul macron toujours disait dimanche sur
le sujet des idéologies nouvelle
manipule des religions prône un
obscurantisme contagieux alors je vous
pose la question et si pure elle
pourquoi emmanuel macron ne me tillie
toujours pas cette menace des démons
anciens c'est qui c'est quoi
écoutez vous savez je moi je vous
renvoie un très beau discours au moment
de l'hommage rendu à arnaud beltrame
discours des invalides qui est fondateur
où les choses sont nommés en nous c'est
nous mais s'est laissé deux hommes oui
mais donc je pense qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans un fait dans un an je pense
que la menace islamiste radicale elle
est identifiée elle et elle ne fait
l'objet d'aucune ambiguïté sur le plan
de 2,2 voilà de l'identification d'un
problème majeur pour notre société
c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs ce que
vous avez vous avez pour mettre un peu
de piment mis l'accent sur un des propos
de monsieur ni neige mais en fait qui
vous le reconnaîtrez aisément vous même
qui disait il ya un petit peu moins de
danger venant de dèche parce que ça
s'est un peu fragilisé en tout cas pour
le moment sur ce fléau par contient
vivier en france et c'est pas pour rien
qu'on à 20 millions d'euros de plus pour
pour la direction générale
oui on va vers niamey qui n'est l'autre
et tout est là partout le lien entre
tous les horizons
hélas oui mais enfin il faut quand même
nom médiateur le sache il y aura dix
mille postes de plus d'ici la fin du
quinquennat il ya une mobilisation du
renseignement de cette menace est prise
très au sérieux ce serait totalement
irresponsable et vous m'accorderez qu'
il ne dit pas le contraire
non mais tu n'as blessés de la garde car
il décale passe depuis 2015 parce que
c'est vrai que la mobilisation
très fort parlera jamais de tous les
attentats déjoués voilà baisser la garde
je crois pas et je crois qu'on a mis des
moyens supplémentaires ça vient d'être
appelé pour effectivement surveiller
tout ça en fait ce qui est dérangeant
c'est cette contradiction chez makro on
vient dire un instant on parle l
international qui dramatise des enjeux
qui fait souvent référence effectivement
aux années 20 aux années 30 j'avais
moins fait attention aux années 30 morts
dans les vins c'est certain shai agassi
parle des années 30
non mais je vois là je vous suis aucun
problème donc il ya vraiment la volonté
est là de dramatiser vraiment les enjeux
vont suivre on comprend et sait quand
même juste étrange quand même que
dramatise pas un tout petit peu de temps
en temps les enjeux quand même
effectivement sur la menace terroriste
islamiste ou probablement quand même les
français s'interrogent sur cette menace
là dans la perspective notamment d'ici à
la fin de l'année prochaine on a une
cinquantaine je crois d'anciens détenus
terroristes islamistes qui vont sortir
et on ce qu'on sait pas quels moyens
seront mis véritablement pour les suivre
on nous promet que d'ailleurs il le dit
dans son interview laurent unis est ce
que on met des moyens supplémentaires
mais il va y avoir des sujets
d'inquiétude on a besoin d'une parole
forte et pour l'instant l'entente alors
vous y faites allusion c'est ce que
christophe castaner aussi ministère
rappelait ce matin il y a une
cinquantaine de condamnés pour
terrorisme qui vont sortir bientôt
présenter 2019 mais on va les suivre
disait-il et il ya tout un dispositif
prévu pour ça on écoute le miz
l'intérieur qui en compte le dernier
liées à ce réseau d'ultra droite on peut
dire si l'attentât si vous attendez des
jouets mais je dirais c'est beaucoup
plus que cela parce que nous intervenons
aussi en amont nous savons et ils savent
que nous surveillons que nous entendons
que nous veillons au quotidien et cela
joue aussi en matière de prévention sur
le risque d'un côté vous pouvez dormir
tranquille moi c'est le rôle d'un
ministre l'intérieur
oui madame cicurel disait on ne parlera
jamais des attentats déjoués puis vous
avez montré la page du journal du
dimanche dont le titre de l'interdît
alors en une heure et cinquante cinq
attentats ont été déjoués
donc ça on en parle on en parle et tout
le problème c'est l'attentât qui ne sera
pas des jouets évidemment parce que dans
l'interview de laurent nyonnaise il dit
à la fois des attaques type bataclan il
ya trois ans aujourd'hui ne sont guère
probable mais on met la menace peut être
aussi une menace intérieure rudimentaire
venant nous venons de radicaliser sur
notre territoire et de ce point de vue
ça n'est guère rassurant le secrétaire
d'état à l'intérieur cite l'exemple de
l'attentât de nice d'attentats demi
s'est excusé moi il a fait quand même 86
morts avec un camion fou sur la
promenade des anglais
ça veut donc dire que la menace elle
reste véritablement très forte alors là
dessus on a effectivement un travail
remarquable qui est fait au quotidien de
suivi des examens de vérification bon
qui fait qu effectivement une action
menée de l'ampleur de ce qu'était le
bataclan avec la coordination toute une
équipe et c est plus difficile qu'avant
nous avons quand même un pays qui ne
peut pas ignorer que la menace islamiste
peut se faire au coin de la rue à
n'importe quel endroit en france et là
ça reste quelque chose qui pèse
lourdement sur le pays est ce que le
président doit en parler davantage
qu'ils ne la fait pas sur le plan de la
menace immédiate pour chaque français il
faut vivre avec
c'est une donnée et en même temps il
faut aussi nommer ce contre quoi nous
nous battons c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel dans la localisation
islamiste en france sur notre territoire
est un problème qu'il faut nommer et
évidemment il faut combattre l'islamisme
radical dans les autres là où il a lieu
dans les autres pays
l ex faut nommer davantage oui je crois
beaucoup aux raisons pouvant pas s'il va
pas faire le procès de vendre ses causes
ne pas faire ce qu'il faut faire je
pense que tout l'appareil d'état
immobilisé et il malgré tout il semble
que ça marche plutôt bien donc voilà que
je pense que laurent du lez en tant
qu'expert de sécurité fondée à dire
qu'il ya sans doute moins de risques là
je suis pas sûr qu'en tant que
secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur pour
dire ces choses là parce que c'est sans
doute vrai mais ensuite politiquement le
dire si la charge et de cash flows bon
bref mes dents parce que la mobilisation
est là les services font leur boulot
bon il leur arrive de laisser passer du
phénomène
jusqu'au président des états unis s'est
elle aurait pu sonner
en tout cas sur cette question du
terrorisme je crois que le travail de
sécurité et les faits c'est vrai que le
travail politique
on sent chez makro une sorte de lucidité
avec lips c'est vrai que le discours de
dar nouvelle trame était magnifique et
c'est vrai qu'il a dit des choses il les
a dit avec beaucoup de courage beaucoup
de fermeté beaucoup de vérité et puis
après on sent que de temps en temps une
espèce de pudeur voulant pas mettre
d'huile sur le feu
neu neu divisons pas en essayant bon on
va leur en veux pas trop en parler ça
s'arrangera tu sais je crois pas je
crois qu'effectivement si on veut
combattre le mur de battre un adversaire
c'est d'avoir de le désigner il ça
suffit pas c'est en désignant les gens
qu'on les bat mais déjà faut commencer
par la désigner donc je pense que de ce
point de vue là de temps en temps il
faudrait vraiment dire les choses et je
trouve que dans la période récente
on a un peu trop tendance je le répète à
nous bourrer le mou avec les hongrois
les polonais et des roumains et un peu
moins avec les vrais péril alors juste
sur ce point je donne et je vous donne
la parole après on écoute aussi le point
de vue de malek boutih ancien président
de sos racisme qui était l'invité
d'europe 1 ce matin
le problème c'est que je dirais on est
forts en défense mais on n'arrive pas à
les attaquer et on n'arrive pas à
empêcher que de nouvelle génération de
terroristes apparaissent c'est
effectivement ça le fond des problèmes
côté je suis absolument ravi que vous
passiez cet extrait que j'avais entendu
ce matin et comme souvent je suis
absolument d'accord avec l'analyse de
malek boutih
je pense que c'est très important ce qui
vient de dire c'est à dire que la
défense vous avez raison verte n'a aucun
fier on est là l'appareil d'état est là
dans sa responsabilité et je pense que
personne ici autour de la table de leur
remettra en cause ce qui est très
important c'est contre l'islam radical
vous avez la tacle et je pense que ça va
venir je veux pas déflorer mais tout ce
qui est prévu même dans l'aménagement de
1905 c'est plutôt ça va dans le sens du
contrôle de l'islam radical en aura
peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler jeu
pas ouvrir ce sujet aujourd'hui
mais ce que dit me viendrait pas en
parler volontiers mais c'est le web
intents soit la france aussi c'est à
dire que yalda volonté si vous voulez au
delà du or c'est une catastrophe c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait soyons pas dans la
commémoration ni l'autre dans la
déploration soyons dans l'action je
pense que commencer
on va essayer à son tour mais je pense
que c'est très important dans ce que dit
malek boutih dans ce petit passage c'est
de dire il faut être présents parce que
l'islam radical
il se développe quand la république
n'est pas là quand la république s'est
retirée et c'est pour ça que bon on fait
un travail de terrain mois à travers je
m'engage pour l'école qui est un
mouvement citoyen que j'ai lancée avec
jean-michel plan caire ou en tout cas
avec j'ose dire sa bénédiction et mais
en toute laïcité en tout
republic and it et on n'en doutera pas
vraiment de lui
je pense que c'est très important il
faut que les citoyens tout le monde doit
se sentir responsable on ne doit pas
laisser dans le dans le en seine saint
denis dans tous dans des territoires
difficiles c'est quand on déserte
quand les républicains déserte qu'il ya
un terrain à prendre et ça c'est ça qui
compte c'est ça qui compte et nous
portons la république en marche
quelques réactions sur ce sujet
la question twitter qu'on vous pose qui
n'est pas un sondage on le rappelle
selon vous la france est elle bien
préparé en cas de nouvel attentat vous
êtes 76% estimé que non et lent qui ne
sera pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
il ne faut pas se préparer à un nouvel
attentat il faut virer davance tous ceux
qui nous haïssent blueberry on n'est
jamais préparé face à la malignité des
islamistes monsieur babineau ans ne
prépare jamais un attentat on est
toujours dans la réaction points de
suspension castaner n'est qu'un pantin
est un incompétent des styles monsieur
babineau et lorient t-mac ajoute c'est
un politicien de second ordre qui n'a
émergé que grâce à son ralliement à
macron les propos sont assez sévère pour
le ministre de l'intérieur je vous
propose maintenant d'aborder là le
feuilleton la semaine celui des gilet
jaune alors la carte des blocages
organisés samedi est un des éléments les
plus consultés sur internet dans cette
espèce de veillée d'armes un peu
étonnante chacun mesure ses forces
ce matin le gouvernement par la voix de
christophe castaner on n'en parlait a
haussé le ton en mettant en garde contre
des blocage complet et de leur côté les
oppositions aux politiques se manifeste
elle un peu en ordre dispersé comme chez
les républicains
on va écouter l'un d'entre eux eric
ciotti député des alpes maritimes il
dénonce une fois de plus le ras-le-bol
fiscale
je veux je les dis depuis plusieurs
jours soutenir cette revendication qui
dépasse très largement le problème des
carburants
aujourd'hui ce qui est en cause c'est le
ras-le-bol fiscale ce mouvement spontané
qui viennent des réseaux sociaux qui
viennent la base ils expriment
aujourd'hui 7
cette colère fiscal que ressemble de
plus en plus de français on se dit ils
peuvent présenter le gouvernement toutes
les mesures qu'ils veulent et je crois
que des annonces seront faites demain
matin ça ne fera
pas composants choses font que c'est
bien possible oui edouard philippe a
priori doit les présenter demain matin
sur cette radio sur rtl
est ce que ça va changer quelque chose
probablement pas et quand on entend eric
ciotti parler du ras-le-bol fiscale on
peut pas mélanger j'ai envie de dire
tous les ras-le-bol fiscaux qui entre
lesquels on peut pas mettre des décide
de le signer galles il ya effectivement
une fiscalité sur l'impôt sur le revenu
il ya une fiscalité sur le travail
là on est en train de parler d'une
fiscalité sur l'écologie est ce qu'il
est patent peut-être de réduire
la fiscalité sur le travail et sur ses
revenus pour augmenter vu la situation
dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui de
renforcer justement de renforcer la
fiscalité sur l'écologie en fait ce qui
était sur la voiture les gens prennent
leur voiture car son travail et je suis
content
non mais oh rejoint parce que je n'avais
je suis pas parler de ce qui se passe
qui se passe là je suis autant dire que
le ras-le-bol fiscal fin jeudi
réorganisons sans doute très globalement
la fiscalité dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui alors après les mesurettes
qu'on va encore nous présenter
maintenant elles changeront rien est-ce
qu emmanuel macron et est-ce que son
premier ministre peuvent ou doivent
céder à tout ça ils ne peuvent pas ils
peuvent pas céder
je veux dire sinon c'est toute la
machine macro nist qui s'est livré
pendant donc ils sont coincés que vous
êtes d'accord c'est pas vrai c'est si
ici un recul c'est c'est toute la
machine qui s'effondre et corps l'idée
du gouvernement edouard philippe
manifestement c'est de céder un peu
avant pour ne pas avoir à céder beaucoup
après c'est à dire qu'on prend un
certain nombre de mesures pour montrer
que le pouvoir n'est pas insensible à la
colère qui n'est pas insensible aux
problèmes énormes de pouvoir d'achat que
des gens modestes qui effectivement
n'ont pas d'autre choix que de prendre
leur voiture le matin pour aller au
travail qui peut être à 40 à 50 km et
qui n'ont pas des revenus élevés et pour
qui le plein de carburant par semaine
grève leur budget donc ça ce message là
il est absolument fondamental que
l'exécutif monde qu'il y est attentif en
même temps et si je puis dire on en
macro ni bien entendu en même temps
l'addition karine becquart dit que on
peut pas mélanger tous les rabaul
fiscaux le problème de ces mouvements
c'est que ça additionne tous les
ras-le-bol c'est le principe des
mouvements de protestation c'est à dire
que vous mélangez tout et alors
effectivement dans un mouvement qui
n'est pas structurée à que vous ne savez
pas très bien qui vous avez affaire et
qui par définition n'a pas de
revendication ultra précise puisque dès
qu'on interroge des gilets jaunes
j'écoutais un certain nombre de
reportages sur les radios ou les chaînes
de télévision à ce moment là on parle
des carburants puis très vite on passe à
d'autres sujets ont dit à mes études là
tu là dessus il faudrait également faire
des choses donc évidemment on ne peut
pas satisfaire les revendications donc
dans cette affaire il faut effectivement
essayé de montrer que le pouvoir n'est
pas insensible qu'il est à l'écouté de
ce que dit le pays mais en même temps
qu'il a une ligne
c'est ça le problème aussi qu'on demande
qu'il a un cap qu'il a du courage
voilà des conditions je dirais qu'ils
sont très rarement réunies par les
politiques et en particulier par les
partis d'opposition qui pratiquent la
surenchère qui ajoute soutiennent
approuve alors que pour les français ils
ont mené une politique de ras-le-bol
fiscale de tout sarkozy puis smaland et
que on voit pas en quoi les républicains
de monsieur ciotti
une société qui soutenait à fond
monsieur fillon dans le programme était
quelque chose de gratiné sur par rapport
à ce que les français pensent on voit
pas en quoi vraiment ça me dit ferrer
les chevaux
il proposait pas de les baisser monsieur
fillon les impôts dans un premier temps
nos merveilleuses non parce que là où le
programme deux filles ont été très dur
et je pense que c'est un des sujets là
c'est sûr là sur la dépense mais je
pense que le fond du problème on peut
tourner autour du pot tant qu'on veut
pourquoi est-ce qu'on augmente les taxes
sur l'essence et des trucs pas parce que
l'écologie d'argent dans les caisses et
que comme on veut pas laisser trop
grandir les déficits on les laisse
grandir un tout petit peu un peu mais
pas que ça aille trop loin
l'argent et on fait ce qu'on fait tous
les gouvernements augmente les taxes sur
l'essence
sauf qu'on est arrivé un moment où les
gens en ont marre et donc ce petit truc
devient un symbole d'un énervement
globale est donc le seul moyen de se
battre contre ça il y en a et le vrai
courage il est là que la droite a pas eu
vous avez raison et que malheureusement
macro n'a pas c'est de se bagarrer
contre la dépense publique le seul moyen
de ne pas augmenter les impôts c'est de
se bagarrer contre la dépense publique
si on touche pas à la dépense
on est condamnés soit laisser filer le
déficit ce qu'on ne peut pas faire
indéfiniment soit augmenter les impôts
ce qu'on fait allègrement et quand on
augmente trop les impôts cependant la
colère des gens et là je crois que je
comprends que gouvernement tente le coup
là on va essayer de lâcher un peu de
lest en espérant à sache que le samedi
se passera quelque chose et puis que
lundi mais les gens lorsqu'on des foules
et ça ira mieux peut-être je peu près
tout autant pour le pays le souhaitez
mais on n'en sait rien il appellera n'en
sais rien et on ne peut pas exclure que
en croit le gouvernant soit contraint de
céder un peu d'abord et puis tout
ensuite
d'autant que je le rappelle qu'on va se
retrouver en janvier avec le prélèvement
à la source et que la l'énervement
fiscal il va pas baisser les donc on est
quand même dans une période donc ça va
être très compliqué cette affaire des
impôts vous parliez dépenses publiques
le lait les enseignants vous allez vous
allez répondre j'ai l'amour errances du
gouvernent mais je voudrais simplement
alors vous allez voir la dépense
physique les enseignants hier manifester
n'étaient pas très nombreux mais le
gouvernement essaye de supprimer des
postes
mais oui mais 0 2% s'émouvoir quand même
comme une addiction des français ont
peut être trop d'ingérence et des poules
toshack était quand on a des postes dans
n'importe quel secteur a donné la parole
à ces querelles fonctionnement donc sur
une augmentation d'impôts
être populaire sur des augmentations
d'impôts ça sert alors il ya beaucoup de
choses à dire
[Musique]
les critiques parce qu'il faut quand
même que que je vous réponde
d'abord c'est pas n'importe quelle
fiscalité j'aurais quand même le dire
il s'agit d'un enjeu écologique majeure
il s'agit pas d'un impôt qui a vocation
à rester c'est un impôt c'est une
fiscalité qui a tendance qui a comme
vocation de changer les comportements
mais c'est une histoire sérieuse il ya
et tout le monde rigole endurera il
parle d'écologie mais non c'est une
conviction du gouvernement vous parliez
d'un câble c'est un quart mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle il n'y aura pas de
recul il n'y aura pas de recul par
contre on va on va essayer de trouver
des moyens si vous voulez de rendre
cette pilule moins amère pour un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes qui sont
particulièrement fragiles et c'est tout
à fait normal mais nous allons chercher
justement ce que disent des amériques
qui s'appelle les américains quand je
dans l'université où j'ai étudié à
harvard et créative auction c'est à dire
des troisièmes voies qui ne sont qu ils
n'ont pas d'effet d'effets pervers par
rapport à la finalité qui est celle
évidemment de résorber en fait petit à
petit luzech de l'essence mais c'est
très important pour c'est très important
parce qu'à 48 mille morts prématurées
chaque année qui sont liées à l' usage
de ces voitures c'est important parce
que il est hypocrite de dire à ces
automobilistes qui ce kit qui vont
travailler avec